that was a good speller you want to
prove it right now okay cuz you not me
how are you at spelling at spelling no
but I cannot believe this purposes at
any point I'm here for you if you need
support that's why I'm here it's fifth
grade you should be home school for
God's sake so first word here we go
spaghetti I use like I can call it pasta
G there's the secret H in there that is
not correct I know whenever I had to
ever spell spaghetti dance school don't
become actors next word is diarrhea
right to it you know you know this one
these are all like hidden H words di a I
hate this game when the teller she's
right no matter what I'm missing in our
yeah just throw it in there somewhere
Jai di Oh Raj I'm sorry that is terrible
diarrhea Raj
Wow I know my diarrhea last one might be
the hardest Mediterranean M EDI
t t smiley face smiley face ended that
was very wrong
meb IP and correct right you're the
first person it's Iranian the only one I
do know how to spell do with that
information what you